où l'on reparle de tchernobyl cette
centrale nucléaire située en ukraine a
été le théâtre en novembre dernier d'un
grave incident classé au niveau 3 sur
l'échelle internationale de sûreté qui
compte sept échelons précision josé
blanc la pièce chère neuville le 27
novembre 1995 alerte dans la salle de
commande de l'autre côté du mur se
trouve le réacteur numéro un
un accident vient de se produire la
fracture du rail qui transporte le
combustible au moment du chargement
la salle est contaminée un employé est
irradié le directeur déclare l'incident
sans gravité
il est classé 1 sur une échelle graduée
jusqu'à 7
dix jours après nous sommes sur place en
reportage au cours de notre visite pas
un mot sur l'incident nous rencontrons
le directeur qui au contraire garantit
la sûreté de sa centrale
depuis dix ans on n'a jamais de gros
accident ici à tchernobyl seulement des
petits problèmes sans gravité trois mois
après l'autorité chargée de la sûreté
des centrales du fan yens donne son avis
l'incident a été minimisé jugé plus
grave à ce 2 1
il est classé 3 sur l'échelle des rires
cette révélation survient à quelques
semaines de l'anniversaire de la plus
grave catastrophe nucléaire de la
planète
déjà il ya dix ans les responsables
avaient mis deux jours pour admettre
l'explosion
depuis tchernobyl fonctionne toujours
les pays industrialisés propose
plusieurs milliards de francs pour sa
fermeture mais pour les ukrainiens la
somme n'est pas suffisante il faut
remplacer la centrale mais aussi des
contaminés la région et mettre les
réacteurs en sécurité ils ont donné leur
accord pour que ferme tchernobyl mais
sans donner de date